do you think do you think women are the
property of men no the point I was like
why have you said they are because I
made a religious point I said that when
a man marries a woman the woman's father
walks him down the aisle walks her down
the aisle and hands her way to the man
traditionally that's what it says in the
Bible I'm a religious person I believe
in God I live in the Muslim so you do
think that the woman becomes the men I
think she takes his last name I mean
let's watch the clip that you said about
sure so that we can get it in context
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false absolutely but I've
I've been married twice as it turns out
and on both occasions I didn't believe
that the woman was being handed to me as
chattel as property it and perhaps the
way that that the reason I'm asked that
question repeatedly and I'm asked in a
loaded way would you rephrase what you
said there now what that's that's an
interesting point about phrasing the way
I would say things before I was famous I
have to take personal responsibility and
accept right that if I make a video that
500 people see and one percent of them
misunderstand it that's not a problem if
I make a video that five million people
see and one percent of Vietnam so
specifically on that point I think my
sister is her husband's property she
took his last name she she married him
she wanted to join his family she has
seen it herself right so she she's still
a sovereign individual she's absolutely
property means that the husband owns
your sister listen my friend if we want
to argue about this you need to go back
to the Bible to the Quran you need to
argue with religious talk about anything
in the Bible of Quran that's what it
says no no I'm asking you what you think
I think that if a woman marries a man
and she decides to take his last name
that they have different roles and
responsibilities within that marriage
and I believe that that's not the
question she's had I believe the father
I am the father behave like a politician
the father hands her to the man right
but don't be a politician because I
think you're a straight talker right you
keep telling me you're straight talk I
think my sister is her husband's
property do you regret saying it like
that I I understand that with my
newfound Fame perhaps it could be
phrased differently however I still
believe that a woman is given to the man
in marriage that's what I believe yeah
but not as property now the property is
the word that other people use the
question but as a an equal partner in a
loving Union that's what marriage
actually means it doesn't mean that when
you get married the woman is given to
you as a bit of Chapel agreed so why say
it but that's the way that people ask me
the question people say to me they asked
the question you can't blame people for
asking you questions surely if you want
to be accountable for what you've said
you've got to own your responses don't
blame the question I own the response
let me ask you a question no and you say
something and then say well actually I
blame you for I understand peers peers I
understand I believe the woman is given
to the man I believe she's given away by
the father I believe she belongs to the
man
fundamentally right so fundamentally you
do believe that a woman becomes a man's
property I believe she belongs to the
man in marriage correct right
I mean see that to me is misogyny and
you're entitled to your opinion right
but do you want do you not understand
why people think it is misogyny I
understand why some people can be very
offended by what I say what they do is
they take a point like that and they
ignore all the other points I make the
other way right that's why that's why
I've repeatedly asked you about that
line to see if you've changed your
position but the reality is you haven't
it's not about changing positions I'm a
full-grown adult and I stick by the
things I say and I'm responsible for
them which by the way is fine absolutely
so what you did say at the start of this
little exchange you said you know I
wouldn't maybe say things the same way
now that I did before I was famous and
yet actually you've doubled down it's
exactly the same thing on certain points
so that is what you believe that's my
point yes I'm trying to work out look I
don't know you we've just met right yeah
I'm trying to work out who Andrew Tate
is and what you actually believe I don't
want to twist anything at all then maybe
make it very very clear to the camera I
believe a woman is given to the man in
marriage I believe that I also believe a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for her I believe a man should lay down
his life if something happens or his
wife's life is threatened I believe that
when women and children first are on the
light boat
honestly literally buy them as a slave
well obviously we're not talking about
that we're talking about religious
biblical marriage we're talking about
something else yeah but I'm a Christian
I don't believe that I I I own my wife
do you believe your wife was given away
to you when she took her last name I
believe that there is a process where a
father traditionally walks his daughter
down the aisle and hands his daughter to
this man and they stand there and become
a union of two loving people in a
partnership no there's no ownership
involved I didn't say he's not selling
her the Father of the Bride isn't
selling his daughter no absolutely
that's what profit Stephen means she
becomes a member of your family I think
we're arguing over semantics Monopoly
because fundamentally I don't believe a
man owns a woman you do well I don't
think a man owns any sovereign
individual I don't think we live in the
world of slavery I don't own any man or
any woman right nobody owns when you use
phrases like property that's what you
imply and so my point again is you're a
smart guy right there's no denying that
you're a smart you're good talker I've
seen a lot of the stuff but when you
what what I don't think you quite fully
understand now I understand when young
impressionable people I understand you
are not as smart see things like I think
my sister is a husband's property yes
and you've just reaffirmed that yeah
that belief they think that they have
the right to own women I understand that
very well Pierce which that's why people
think you're a misogynist completely I
understand all of this very well which
is why when you're saying I was
backtracking I'm not I'm generally
regret though over the way you phrase
this stuff well this is the point I was
trying to make
the point I'm trying to make is when I
was not nearly as famous and I was
making long format content I was not
sitting there anticipating I've become
the most Googled man in the planet and
that few seconds can be taken out of
context that was not my anticipation but
it's not what you believed it is what
you believe now so what's the difference
it's not about it's not you're asking me
you're saying that young people who are
impressed you said to me look look
please honestly I've had time to think
about this and I wish I hadn't said it I
don't believe that that's one thing
actually you've said the opposite you
said actually that's what I think yeah I
think that when uh so it doesn't really
matter whether you recorded it when you
famous or not famous it's what you
actually believe right I believe that a
man has a duty to protect and provide
for a woman I believe that uh a woman's
father gives her away to the man that's
what I believe and that's in in my
marriage that's that's the circumstance
I'm going to live under if people want
to live in a different scenario that's
completely theirs they're prerogative